wait til you waiting you know hi i'm  grady sage and this is why i should be  on the next season of The Bachelor not  beating grass hey the only issues I have  our lactose and an inability to open up  emotionally one of my favorite  activities is drinking in a house all  day and then just seeing what happens  don't hate it don't don't eat it I'm an  animal lover I love drama lying and Fox  oh so basil no it's not your I don't do  dishes because plates are hard too I get  rashes inside this is enough it's not  this time ah no stop eating grass chores  new banana who dis I'm hilarious  you must been issues but staff I think  we got it they show you when I have hook  on when you're for your audition tape I  watch movies without sound because I'm a  great lip reader that's an innuendo Wow  you know no you're good lip reader  mm-hmm how's that sexual dick